you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chess calm
and I just got paired up playing a 3-2
game okay let's see what we get here
I think I'm gonna go for a Kings Indian
defense yeah why not
okay they're going for a fee and kiddo
it's just Castle c5 you know let's play
c5 and maybe even go for a gambit line
which takes and then maybe even d6 let's
give this a shot looking for some play
against their Queen side Knight takes
pawn takes Bishop takes rook b8 having
two pieces in some way converge on b2
can be a little bit uncomfortable if
white isn't taking I could think about
this and why not let's do it I'd like to
just offset this Bishop and I think I
could get that in now a knight takes
Bishop c6 seems fine to be a little bit
careful of this battery here against g7
hmm isn't that a mistake and it takes
here and we trade a bunch I think all
minor pieces are off the board and then
I'm up upon it appears that way Knight
takes Queen takes Bishop King takes
Knight here discover check King here I
don't see the good follow up I have f6
under control I think this is just a
mistake okay guess they're gonna have to
show me
I don't see it Queen set yeah so that
was a blunder okay and let's see if I
could convert this is there any other
move besides this I don't think so
and okay do I have any in-between move
I don't think so let's just recap sure
so I'm playing this up a pond now I
think the Queen is a little bit
inconvenienced if I take the bishop
releasing pressure from here or should I
think about ecigs and d5
my Queen to f6 yeah that's maybe not a
bad idea huh
hang on guys a little bit fearful of a
queen check and then this pawn is hit so
let's do it like this and then look for
this d5 move strong point hey let's get
these guys going and maybe even a five
playing very fast mm-hmm all right well
they're not doing anything about this
advance so let's get moving in the
center okay let's just go here for
starters don't allow that pawn push so
easily all right how about right here
then maybe snake in with my queen I'm
doing this to also stop rook there
all right let's offset this rook a
minute for not okay
defend an e5 and look to pile up on b5
that's a little bit of a weird move they
have to defend that beep on now
King g7 is met with f4 hmm can i triple
up let's go here
Queen f6 King g7 interesting all right
well I could also transfer my attention
now to the e-file their king is very
exposed I have a better home for my king
now up upon and possible clean exchanges
hunting down the B pond might end up in
a single rook position all right hmm I
guess we'll go here for starters I have
back rank issues they control this
flight square I wasn't really too afraid
of that all right yeah it's insert a
check on off time though let's keep it a
little bit simple and go with this
defend c6 slowly improve it's still
tactical for as long as both rooks
remain on board all right let's improve
my king position slightly and let's go
here and then right here keep pressure
on everything okay I think I want to be
able to hunt down this pawn they have to
do that
let's cut their King off for starters
interesting okay it's looking more like
a draw now three versus two I don't know
let's let them run for a little bit make
them struggle to get this pawn maybe
yeah I guess they're gonna get that
alright let's see if I could try to win
this three versus two
first things first cut the King off and
what next I need to improve my King
position and of course keep an eye on
the clock they're doing similar cutting
my King off that's the right approach so
we're gonna go here preparing to block
or rook check as I advance my king up
I'll probably challenge my rook let's do
it like this
hmmm let's come over here
maybe rook d7 do I really have to go
about it like this now let's try
something different I'm gonna go here
just to make sure there's not a
repetition if the King goes to e you
want to have rook g2 and then the rook
has to defend the Jeep on so I guess the
rook is going to step up again stopping
my king from moving forward let's try
here hmm they're defending well okay
what can I try with ten seconds let's
try this again King coming out I kind of
give a check for a rook exchange it's a
one King and pawn ending alright a
little bit of success with my King pawn
push I have a check so now I won't have
to move him okay that might be a little
bit of a mistake so I have this idea now
stops the King from getting here push
and then rook here
maybe might have something maybe I might
be able to hunt this pond down
coordinate a g4 well I might as well
just put it on the board
get my rook on h3 let's go here watch I
don't get made it who actually my rook
isn't even in a good is not even in a
good position to dislodge their King
just come over here they're just gonna
go here right yeah I guess they're
holding it huh my king is cut off guys
got to take the drop
yeah they agreed hmm how could I have
done better in the middle game because
once it got to the endgame there it was
tough the three versus two it's gonna be
a draw so let me go into it they just
made a mistake early on and I picked up
a pawn but alright let's have a look at
it first just without the engine so I'm
offering of a pawn here and my
compensation is some Queen site pressure
b2 maybe Bishop h3 Queen coming out here
a knight reposition to one of these two
unleashing the bishop they didn't go for
it though and it's pretty quiet what
would be better around here maybe Knight
d5 not being so quick to make too many
exchanges or even trying to establish
let's say any pawn in the center this
might be an idea certainly wouldn't want
to capture being mate in one so maybe
this is a better approach Knight to d5
instead of e4 of course
so they dropped that pun but how could I
have done better around here already
this is the one moment or I should have
done something different maybe I felt
like it was an okay idea to establish a
strong point on d5 initially I wanted to
do this or excuse me I wanted to do this
after they recaptured on c3 I wanted to
play e6 and if they take that way I have
a good spot for my queen but this coin
check is a little bit uncomfortable if
I'm playing here then they grab the pawn
so that's why I switch things up in the
end win with the capture and only then e
six the difference here the main
difference that I'm seeing at least is
that I can't easily let's say I offset
their strong post can't offset their
Queen well I can't challenge it with
Queen f6 no I don't have control over
the f6 square with my king I think
that's a fine approach what I'm doing
here playing D 5 and then 85 hmm
I'm weak on these dark squares so I need
to get some control back over them it
could be tricky to do them I got e 5 I
mean because they could be doing what
instead of the pawn push they could have
considered rook here and then maybe even
now for move and it's tough for me to
get my central my to does your majority
going in the center I got a e5 in rook
b8 it's probably not the best move I
should have played Queen c7 I was just
doing this to stop rook a 6 but Queen c7
and rook d7 r f e8
I think right around here where the
structure changes some there's something
else I could be doing now that their
King is the more exposed I defend their
offering a queen exchange maybe here
yeah probably here this is where the
computer will be able to suggest
something I have a past pond they have
the more exposed King so why am i why am
i exchanging Queens
keep the Queen's on board I have f7
defended it's true he's strictly
defensive I do I do have two free pieces
hmm not quite I was ready to say I have
two free pieces the Queen in my e8 rook
that can be attacking but he does have
some defensive responsibilities my rook
on ei as otherwise rook to e8 and my
king is in trouble
but I could start with Queen III and
then maybe you look to target this pawn
or land some more checks I don't know
it's maybe a little bit tough here
suppose the King hides on h3
they have active pieces yeah every every
piece that they have is active well
we're gonna see what the computer
suggests around here once the Queen side
pawns were all exchanged possibilities
that this ends in a draw increase
greatly you know I don't think I could
really win this now maybe one last
detail is after I cut the King off maybe
I should consider this move first yeah
this is a little bit different like once
we are in this ending
I think stopping h4 because what did I
end up struggling to do activate my king
and also keep my rook in a position to
cut the White King off if I start with
g4 right here I
stoppage for for one and I at least
allow my King to inch up an additional
rank with the help of my F pawn I get to
play to f6 and then my King to g6 and
maybe even stuff like this starts to
become a possibility if I can get my
King to h3 then it's pretty serious for
white pretty critical for white to come
up with something accurate maybe there
wouldn't be anything if my king is
getting that far but I think as a start
here even though it's usually usually
chalk it up as aa three versus two same
side of the board likely draws to come
about I think it's important I begin
with this g4 instead of what did I do
I played h5 and after h4 it's tough for
me to get my King working this pawn is
in my King's way and I can't do this so
easily you know we saw what they were
doing they were cutting my King off just
like I'm doing to their king so if I
could do it over I would play g4 in this
ending which is still probably a draw
but this I think is at least a better
attempt in this rook ending to begin
with g5 I don't know if they're waiting
f6 if they're still waiting at least I'm
making some progress here and maybe even
stuff like this mmm
maybe they have to stop my king actually
but I don't know even even this pawn
could maybe start to contribute in a way
and this is a new square for my King if
they're taking maybe I inch my king up
to g5 having upon an h3 might allow some
checks and then when my rep moves again
there's possibilities for me I don't
know it's likely better try is the short
story for me to try g4 instead of
loosing me g5 instead of h5 but let's
see what we could take away from this
one I'm going to pull it up on stock
fish and see where we can make some even
more improvement
okay stockfish let us see what we can
learn no no let's get to something
critical notice that there's this
compensation as mentioned rook b8 wants
to return the bishop right away
Queen a5 down upon but I have a lot of
activity slight lead development wise
Queen c2 Bishop d7 the other are coming
to c8 no pad well they didn't bite
should be seven you know so that's a
mistake
what about ninety five okay that's what
it does like ninety to d5 then Bishop
takes d5 or even line to which you can't
see is popping up Knight h5 stuff like
this takes Bishop takes rook v8 and then
the knight returns night versus Bishop
I'll be looking for b5 okay
they dropped upon how could I have
converted this better what about here
this is the first moment I took okay c5
hmm well I'm playing c5 I mean nothing's
still going to have pressure here hmm
h4 h5 stuff huh I got to stop this
advance clean III look here I want to go
with a five I guess it's okay to defend
like this and then just try for this
stuff keeping the structure like this
yeah I thought it was alright though
it's how I played it with getting in d5
yeah this isn't
this isn't bad I guess there's a couple
different ways we could be setting up
the pawn structure at least get in 85 so
it's more than even upon advantage
probably miss something when they move
their F pawn I went out I think there
will be some evaluation shift then okay
they missed something there after they
played rook 85 Queenie 6 hmm let me
share something right now that I didn't
voice while I was playing and that is I
considered d4 but I ruled it out because
the white can reply with Queen here I
was even in some position I was thinking
oh if I get in d4 and they play Queen c4
maybe I could get my Queen here and
offer a queen exchange how after after
take stakes then they have to connected
passed pawns but what if I prep this d4
idea with what's being suggested here
Queenie 6 which is paving the way for d4
just make a nothing and let me just make
a nothing move it's favoring the way for
D for Queen of course can't go here and
now I can all they have to watch over
the B pond but now I can't at least
improve my Queen position it really
doesn't get much better than this spot
right here who's gonna argue with that
Queen position right in the center
defend c6 and I believe that she is the
most efficient defender of c6 devoting
of devoting a rook to the c6 pawns
defense
the rook is much more inconvenience than
the Queen is I in fact don't even really
see the Queen as being inconvenienced
defending c6 look at her functioning on
this diagonal here and yeah I mean this
already renews back rank issues so this
will in some way tie the black pieces up
to defending should the file open up
should I gain control over the a file
they have to worry about me getting to
their first rank short story here is
that I should have maybe looked into
improving my queen position I mean she's
pretty sad right here in c8 and she
could do much better
Queenie 6d for Queen d5 and that's as
far as I have to take it I don't have to
calculate several moves deep here I only
have to look to see or maybe better
stated I have to ask myself that
important question where when my queen
really stand well they are absent
they're LightSquared Bishop of course
I'm with on my dark square Bishop this
was a bit of an inconvenience to me
earlier on I felt it in the game when
the Queen was functioning on this
diagonal that's why I was making a move
like rook to e8 so I could kind of cut
the Queen off from controlling these
dark squares from seeing f6 from seeing
g7 well how would white feel if I had a
queen doing similar observing f3 G to H
1 that would be really inconvenient so
that's just another I don't know in a
way a cue for me to look more into these
type of moves a cue for me to know how I
could have better improved my pieces
they have a really strong Queen on this
diagonal what about I get a queen here
one day okay
anyhow didn't come up with that
improvement for my Queen
therefore it's still just a pawn
advantage nothing different decisive
Queen III Queenie one anything wrong
with that other is something wrong with
that Queenie to King III Queen but what
am I missing here there's just lighting
up Oh Queen e2 any and suppose here oh
you idiot rook is hanging they can't
play here cuz I gave a check and I'm
getting this guy oh I was completely
blind to this huh I you know what I
never even said to myself during this
game oh this is an unprotected piece
might white be tactically vulnerable as
soon as their King was vulnerable like
this after they moved their F pawn you
know I should have noted these two
things the rook is unprotected the King
is more vulnerable I noted that the king
was more vulnerable but I was I wasn't
looking to take advantage of this roof
post on a6 yeah
Queen e3 that's no good there's the good
thing there goes the rook so they would
have to do something like rook f2 and
it's still a struggle rookie the c8
don't want to play that mm-hmm okay yeah
that doesn't seem right
so we exchanged and I guess this really
isn't amounting to anything this ending
these are all exchange rooks II - I
played +2
just take and then oh I still have
something here huh goes here I have rook
here well I should have kept the rooks
on huh hmm I know it's going to be very
difficult if these Queen site pawns are
exchanged and there's just a single rook
on board why did I not consider to keep
it more tactical to better maximize this
well I'm gonna try to win that's that's
the better environment to keep on board
one where both rooks are on board I
still have their King cut off there's
even back rank issues this is throwing a
maken one threat and I'm looking to also
just have two pigs on the second hmm
made it too easy on white this is a way
I can make them struggle some more just
to immediately take realize that they're
gonna hunt him down but let's at least
keep two rooks on board yeah all righty
one rook on board is it suggesting g5
here not quite kind of a nothing move
rook to B to G 500 d4 and
it's still gonna be a draw oh okay rook
d4 with this idea to welcome another
pawn exchange yeah and this is still
going to be a draw a good little tip
though to be familiar with I mean the
more that white could make pawn
exchanges the better off so and there's
g5 move white wants to get in this
so it's prepped and then we have this
exchange incoming the H pawn for the
Jeep on and then the two versus one tens
even more towards being a draw in in in
the two versus one that ate three versus
two and I doubt that there was anything
that really this went into the 80s move
eighty some and I don't think there was
ever anything it's just lingering around
one point seven which is nothing yeah if
they're not if they're not careful you
know I'm threatening meeting to stuff
but they did well enough to just kick my
king away from defending g5 and then I
don't have this mating idea anymore and
they could just go checking me like
crazy and I think even right here rook
over is like they eventually did but
just right away they could have done
this and then hunted down my pawn but
either way yeah it's a draw
okay well I know that I learned a couple
things from this one reviewing it with
the computer I hope you did as well and
as usual feel free to leave any comments
in the comment section below
that's all for now take care bye